bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat dans quelques instants vous allez
pouvoir suivre l'examen du projet de loi
de finances rectificative pour 2009
ce collectif budgétaire comporte les
mesures annoncées par nicolas sarkozy
lors du sommet social du 18 février
dernier ainsi que les mesures de
financement du pacte automobile
ce collectif budgétaire révise également
à les prévisions en matière de déficits
publics le déficit public de la france
qui pourrait grimper jusqu'à 5,6 pour
cent du pib en 2009
bonne séance à tous sur public sénat à
l'article 4 nous avons l'amendement 32
présentée par monsieur carrère
oui madame la présidente de monsieur le
ministre depuis 2007 le gouvernement
tente de réformer la défense le livre
blanc sur la défense et la sécurité
nationale et la rgpp on aurait un cadre
à cette réforme
les grandes lignes sont connues faire
plus avec moins
tout en poursuivant l'alignement
atlantiste commencé alors que george
bush était le président des états unis
hors deux faits majeurs sont venues
bousculer cette architecture
d'une part la crise financière
économique et sociale du capitalisme et
de l'autre l'élection de barack obama
qui est en train de changer les
priorités de sécurité de défense des
états unis et qui aura certainement un
impact sur les alliés une réforme menée
à contretemps des présupposés financier
démentie par l'évolution d'une crise à
laquelle le gouvernement essaie
d'apporter des réponses contre 1 qu'il
est de procéder dans le désordre des
réajustements qui se succèdent sans
cesse brouillant ainsi une stratégie
déjà mises à mal par la réalité par le
manque de réactivité
or la situation est grave et nous
créions que vos erreurs face se peser de
graves dangers sur les personnels de la
défense civile et militaire ainsi et
nous sommes dans notre rôle que sur les
territoires touchés par vos projets les
bases de défense les délocalisations de
l'it et militaires les fermetures
d'établissements exige d'améliorer
l'accompagnement des personnels par
ailleurs s'agissant de l'aménagement du
territoire le dispositif me laisse si
vous permettez monsieur merci quelque
peu dubitatif quant au monde dans non
c'est pas grave provisionner et aux
critères d'attribution des aides sur les
320 millions d'euros dédiés à
l'accompagnement des territoires 200
verts sont prélevés sur le budget de la
défense laissant d'autres relevant du
secrétariat d'état chargé de
l'aménagement du territoire la mise en
oeuvre des critères d'éligibilité aux
divers 10
div l'accompagnement manque par ailleurs
de lisibilité sans mettre en doute de la
bonne volonté et la mobilisation des
ministères je me demande très
sincèrement si l'enveloppé insuffisante
au regard de l'ampleur de la réforme et
de ses conséquences humaines et
territoriales
cet amendement a donc pour objet de
mieux financer le processus de
restructuration en cours actuellement
les mesures décidées par le gouvernement
implique des suppressions d'emplois et
des regroupements géographiques
considérable or les dotations prévues
pour faire face et pour accompagner les
restructurations sont insuffisantes
en conséquence il est proposé d'affecter
à l'action restructuration qui figure
dans le programme soutien de la
politique de défense de la loi de
finances initiale pour 2009 75 millions
d'euros
990 1872 millions d'euros en
autorisations d'engagement et en crédits
de paiement
en contrepartie il est proposé de
réduire à due concurrence les crédits
affectés à l'action maîtrise des
capacités technologiques et
industrielles qui figure dans le
programme environnement être prospective
de défense nous savons mesdames et
messieurs que le gouvernement aux prises
avec une réalité économique et sociale
difficile s'apprêterait à annuler des
crédits de la mission défense
je souhaite en revanche que ces crédits
soit mieux utilisé et n'ont pas diminué
et en particulier employés à pallier les
conséquences sur les personnels et sur
les territoires des à griffes des très
agressive restructuration en cours si
chaque collègue la vie de la commission
nous pouvons comprendre les
préoccupations exprimées par notre
collègue monsieur carrère en ce qui
concerne les restructurations de défense
qui sont lourdes à assumer pour les
collectivités concernées malgré les
différentes aides déjà prévus
par l'état et ceux qui ne nous semble
malheureusement pas acceptable dans cet
amendement c'est de prélever sur les
études amont les études préalables au
lancement d'un programme d'armement et
j'ai entendu notre collègue carrère
s'alarmer sur ce qu'il appelle
l'alignement atlantiste
c'est bien en faisant des études amont
que l'on peut se prémunir contre ce type
de risque et préserver l'avenir vous
voyez donc je me permets de de mettre en
valeur cette contradiction dans votre
amendement et qui est me conduit à
insister sur l'avis défavorable de la
commission et la vie du midi du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
présidente
le gouvernement ne venez pas d'un avis
favorable nous avons reçu le sénateur
carrère déjà inscrits dont 320 millions
pour accompagner les restructurations
elles sont lourdes il est vrai mais la
somme est également une somme importante
il est prévu en 2009 sur ses 320 ceux
des autorisations d'engagement il est
prévu 177 millions d'euros de crédits
donc ça montre que le gouvernement prend
en compte la taille de ces de ses
restructurations donc la question n'est
pas là cela étant il est à un pilotage
très précis de ses dépenses et je vais
dans votre sens
donc il ya un pilotage très précis de
ces dépenses il ya un comité qui suit ça
en lien entre la défense et le budget et
donc nous allons suivre ça précisément
et si jamais il s'avérait qu'il des
crédits supplémentaires à inscrire pour
accompagner ces restructurations alors
nous le ferions avec des redéploiements
de crédits à partir des crédits des
programmes de la mission défense
je souhaite avec l'année se passer nous
ferons un point sur l'utilisation des
crédits en réalité et s'il faut abondé
on fera quelques quelques équilibre
entre les crédits de la mission ce que
vous aussi
les explications de vote oui monsieur
carrère mois la mine la réponse que me
fait monsieur le ministre du budget est
une réponse qui avance de plutôt dans le
bon sens la seule question que je me
pose moi est-ce qu'il va y avoir
vraiment une diminution du budget de la
mission défense parce que si tel est le
cas moi je souhaiterais alors à voir
l'engagement des gouvernements que cette
diminution des crédits de la mission
défense serait ipso facto redéployés à
l'intérieur du budget de la défense et
pourrait être affecté
justement à ces opérations
d'accompagnement de restructuration
sinon je vais te dire mon amendement
monsieur le ministre est une réponse à
monsieur car erp donc bien vous mettez
votre amendement monsieur carrère bien
alors je mets au voile amendements
présentés par monsieur carrère et rob
socialistes ceux qui sont favorables son
adoption au don bien levé la main ceux
qui sont contre il n'est pas adoptée
alors nous passons aux amendements du
gouvernement
est ce que vous les présenter
individuellement ou regroupée le
permettez je vais le présenter de façon
groupée donc
ces amendements sont au nombre de douze
le modifie d'une part l'article iv et
les tabs et annexé relatifs aux
ouvertures auxquels procède ce projet de
loi de finances rectificative et d'autre
part l'article 5 et les tabs et annexé
relatifs aux annulations ces amendements
sont de deux natures différentes
il s'agit d'abord de répondre
favorablement aux propositions de
réimputation de crédit présenté par
votre commission des finances
ces modifications de crédit qui impacte
plusieurs missions sont neutres sur le
sol depuis ce qu'elles conduisent à des
ouvertures d'un montant total de 481
milles euros compensées par des
annulations de même montant deuxième
point il s'agit d'ouvrir 200 millions
d'euros de crédits supplémentaires afin
d'assurer le financement du fonds de
sécurisation du crédit interentreprises
dans la création fera l'objet d'un autre
amendement lors de la discussion de
cette seconde partie du collectif c'est
l'amendement 90 du gouvernement qui se
situe après l'article 8 c'est donc le
lay l'assureur l'assurance crédit en
fait à le fait de pouvoir doper l
assurance-crédit ses 200 millions
permettront de couvrir une capacité
maximale de 5 milliards d'euros de
risques chez les assureurs crédit cette
ouverture de crédits supplémentaires
s'effectue sur la mission plan de
relance de l'économie n'est donc pas
gagée par des annulations de crédits sur
d'autres missions elle fera l'objet
d'une coordination dans l'article
d'équilibré en fin de deuxième partie
tout à l'heure merci l'avis de la
commission
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la commission se réjouit du dispositif
qui est ici proposée en matière
d'assurance crédit
il s'agit du fonds de sécurisation du
crédit interentreprises et se font comme
l'a indiqué le ministre a pour objet de
garantir aux bénéfices des entreprises
le risque de non-paiement des encours de
crédit client qui ne peuvent plus être
prise en charge par les assureurs crédit
soit parce que l'assureur a retiré sa
garantie sans risque rien donné
soit parce qu'il a refusé de couvrir ce
client alors vous vous souvenez que nous
avions en fin d'année
mis en place un régime de partenariat
entre les assureurs crédit et la caisse
centrale de réassurance mais ceux-ci
supposer que les assureurs crédit
poursuivent leur mission
la caisse centrale de réassurance
n'intervenant qu'à titre partenariale
comme je les dis en fait complémentaires
dès lors que la révision des positions
des assureurs crédit a été plus prononcé
qu on aurait pu le penser
ce dispositif n'a pas eu jusqu'à ce jour
le succès escompté et il est absolument
nécessaire de passer à une vitesse
supérieure
c'est à mon avis monsieur ministre l'une
des dispositions importantes de ce
collectif budgétaire parce que nous ne
cessons d'avoir des échos dans nos
départements de problèmes liés à la
situation de petites et moyennes
entreprises dont la trésorerie est
fragilisée par la révision de la
cotation de leurs créances commerciales
et est donc par le retrait des assureurs
crédit et qui joue un rôle important en
temps normal pour assurer le bon
fonctionnement du crédit
interentreprises donc monsieur le
ministre je me réjouis de cette solution
qui va être déclinée par d'autres
dispositions qui va être accompagnée
d'autres dispositions et cc c'est bien
la preuve que le gouvernement a été
attentif aux remontées de nombreux
messages sur ce sujet qui n'ont cessé de
lui parvenir au cours des dernières
semaines
monsieur le ministre vous avez demandé
la parole oui parce que le la présidente
le rapporteur a eu raison d'insister
là-dessus juppé s'est vite en me disant
que au fond je pourrais le présenter
plus tard mais autant le faire
même temps que les crédits ce sera très
rapide mais le rapporteur général l'a
déjà très bien fait vous il ya
effectivement des problèmes d'assurance
crédit
chacun le sait le voit dans toutes les
réunions qui peut qui peut faire donc le
gouvernement avait déjà pris en fin
d'année 2008 des mesures pour habiliter
la caisse centrale de réassurance
habilités à effectuer avec la garantie
de l'état des opérations de réassurance
des entreprises d'assurance crédit
mais c'est pas suffisant on le voit bien
et se produit d'ailleurs qui s'appelle c
ap complément d'assurance-crédit public
ce complément d'assurance-crédit public
n'est pas suffisant on le voit vous avez
vous même beaucoup de contacts avec les
entreprises
donc le dispositif que nous vous
proposons et donc les 200 millions
d'euros d'ouverture de crédits
permettent de créer un dispositif
supplémentaire ca fait plus dispositif
supplémentaire d'assurance crédit qui
sera également distribué par les
assureurs crédit qui conserveront à leur
charge afin de les responsabiliser un
seul c'est très important une
participation résiduelle au risque qu
ils transfèreront un fonds doté de 200
millions que vous avez que vous êtes en
train de créer si vous votez 7,7 des
amendements du gouvernement
ce fonds permettra à la caisse centrale
de réassurance de couvrir jusqu'à cinq
milliards d'euros de crédits
interentreprises au bénéfice des
entreprises que les assureurs crédit ont
renoncé à couvrir ce qui est le cas
actuellement sur la base de conventions
avec ces mêmes assureurs crédit donc ce
qu'il repousse aujourd'hui ils pourront
elles accepté on a des entreprises qui
ont des vues très mauvaises surprises en
ce moment le nouveau produit sera
accessible à toutes les entreprises qui
se sont vu notifier un retrait total de
garanties ou un refus de garantie sur un
client donné lorsque celui ci relève
d'une qualité de crédit intermédiaire
le fonds ne s'exposera pas à des risques
d'entreprise dont la cessation de
paiement apparaîtrait comme quasi
certaine ni al'inverse au risque
actuellement assurables par le marché
par ailleurs
le la caisse centrale le fallait
le dispositif existant sera élargi aux
garanties obligatoires des sous
traitants des constructeurs de maisons
individuelles qui est un cas tout à fait
particulier nous constatons aujourd'hui
que les assureurs crédit réduisent leur
exposition dans ce domaine et ceux ci
risquent de pénaliser fortement les
sous-traitants du secteur de la
construction
donc là c'est aussi une réponse toute
particulière un sujet extrêmement
compliqué voilà un peu ce que je peux
dire en complément de ce qu'a dit
monsieur le rapporteur général pour vous
éclairer totalement sur ce crédit de 100
millions qui va j'imagine dans le sens
que chacun souhaite poursuivre il
monsieur le ministre explications de
vote monsieur jégo monsieur le ministre
je me réjouis de cette disposition
puisque c'est vrai que on vous avait à
plusieurs reprises alerté sur cette tour
cette affaire la question et je veux
très bien entendu pour la question que
je me pose c'est s'il y avait encore des
grippages dans ce ce système use avait
alimenté donc de 200 millions d'euros
est ce qu'il y aurait pour les pme elles
mêmes principes qu'elle puisse se
retournait finalement vers le médiateur
pour traiter de dossiers un qui aurait
qui auraient des découle pas lui qui
aurait une couverture intermédiaire
c'est évidemment là il fait vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure très bien d'ailleurs
et pour des petites pme qui se trouve
être fragile mais qui n'ont pas bien sûr
d'un pays avérés mais qui n'ont même pas
d'incident bancaire puisque finalement
c'est là dessus que se joue
un peu la finesse des assureurs crédit
c'est de dire de décréter
unilatéralement qu'il y à un risque trop
important pour que le système
d'assurance-crédit fonctionne alors est
ce que finalement il pourrait y avoir le
parallélisme des formes
et est ce que le médiateur est habilité
pour arbitrer également en matière
d'assurance crédit
messieurs ministre monsieur le sénateur
jégou oui le médiateur est à la fois
compétent en termes de crédit voilà 5 %
des dossiers de médiation sont déjà sont
déjà sondé concerne déjà l'assurance
crédit donc le médiateur est compétent
que c'est votre question pour traiter
des dossiers d'assurance crédit comme
des dossiers de crédit
merci il n'y a pas d'autres explications
de vote
je vais mettre aux voix le l'amendement
91 du gouvernement ceux qui sont
favorables au don bien l'exprimer en
levant la main ceux qui sont contre il
est adopté est ce qu'on procède de la
même façon pour l'amendement 99
mais ma vie sans qu elle vote 102 même
vote 104 même vote à monsieur raoult sur
le centquatre monsieur raoul la
présentation de moshin ministre a été
pour le moins succincte
j'aurais préféré qu'on me dise
exactement le contenu de l'amendement
104 quels sont les besoins de paiement
sur la mission 4 sur l'action 4 2 les
programmes formation supérieur et
recherche universitaire à quoi ça
correspond à ses besoins de paiement
bien l'avis du l'avis de la commission
je précise à notre collègue qu'il s'agit
d'un redéploiement pour une somme très
limité au total cinquante mille euros +
50 mille moins 50000 donc c'est une
ventilation de chapitres à chapitre
c'est tout ce n'est pas une innovation
par rapport au mas de c2c de ces
programmes
nous sommes dans l'extrême détail c'est
de répondre aux souhaits comme ceci a
été dit des parlementaires bien ses
explications et en donner je mets au
voile un amendement 104 alors ceux qui
sont favorables à son adoption
ceux qui sont contre
il est adopté même avis pour la bonne
l'amendement 105 et l'amendement 106 et
l'amendement 108 même avis adopté alors
je fais voter sur l'article 4
ceux qui sont favorables à l'adoption de
cet article cas devront bien levé la
main ceux qui sont contre il est adopté
nous passons à l'article 5 et ab prime
la parole est un monsieur michel teston
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chères et chers collègues elle
et ab prime annexé au projet de loi
présente la répartition par mission des
crédits annulé pour 2009
à la lecture de cette répartition
constate que la mission la plus touchée
par les annulations de crédits la
mission écologie développement et
aménagement durables avec 55,7 millions
d'euros d'annulations en autorisations
d'engagement et 63 2 6 millions d'euros
d'annulations en crédits de paiement
cela représente 21% du total des
autorisations d'engagement annulés un
peu plus de 24 % du total des crédits de
paiement annulé au titre de l'article 5
le second constat est qu'au sein de
cette mission
le programme infrastructures et services
de transport perd 35 8 millions d'euros
en autorisations d'engagement et 40,5
millions d'euros en crédits de paiement
soit dans les deux cas environ 64% des
annulations de crédits de la mission
selon les informations dont je dispose
ces annulations de crédits porte sur les
crédits de réserve de précaution voter
hollande finances initiale en
application de la lolf
qu'en est il réellement il semble que
les crédits annulés et redéployer porte
près
si palm en sur le concours de l'état à
rff concours qui sont au nombre de trois
la contribution charge d'infrastructures
la subvention non renouvellement et de
mise aux normes
la subvention de désendettement ainsi
alors que des moyens financiers
supplémentaires ont été apportées à rff
avec la première loi de finances
rectificative pour 2009 le gouvernement
fait en partie marche arrière
avec ce deuxième budget rectificatif
comment ne pas rappeler que rff a hérité
d'une dette colossale et que son conseil
d'administration a approuvé le 12 mars
dernier un programme complémentaire d'
investissement de 300 millions d'euros
visant à accélérer les opérations de
régénération du réseau et à consacrer
plus de crédit aux études de nouvelles
lignes à grande vitesse et à leurs
travaux préparatoires sur ministre
pouvez vous me confirmer que les
annulations de crédits concerne rff
dans l'affirmative pourquoi cet
arbitrage budgétaire défavorable à rff
alors qu'il y a tant à faire pour
développer les modes de transport
alternatifs à la route
le ferroviaire particulièrement et alors
que le processus législatif du grenelle
suit son cours merci monsieur le
sénateur le léman la réponse de monsieur
le ministre est madame est à présent
tout il n'ya pas d'incohérence à
afficher des annulations de crédits
évidemment dans le cadre du collectif
même en période de relance il s'agit de
correctement géré la gestion des crédits
c'est extrêmement important je rappelle
l'imd présentation déficit de crise
déficit courant donc il faut continuer à
tenir là la dépense et ne rien abandonné
là dessus et d'ailleurs on remarque
qu'on a je trouve bien tenu la dépense 1
% de dépenses en volume sur l'ensemble
des finances publiques
en 2008 c'est pas si pas si mal donc il
s'agit d' annulation de crédits mais ces
annulations de crédits elles permettent
de compenser des ouvertures de crédits
qui ne participent pas
de la politique de relance de l'économie
je pense par exemple au financement de
mesures comme ce qui se passe sur la
tempête klaus ou ce genre de choses qui
n'a qui demandent de l'argent
supplémentaire mais qui n'ont pas liées
à la relance donc elles sont financées
par annulation de crédits et les
annulations de crédits sur le programme
infrastructures et services de transport
de la mission écologie norme est pas du
tout en cause
l'effort d'investissement routier
ferroviaire fluvial
cet effort est complètement préservée la
feets un budget déjà voté donc il n'est
pas modifié mais rff a arrêté son
programme d'investissements pour 2009
donc ya pas il n'ya pas il n'y a pas de
problème les annulations portent sur la
réserve de précaution
donc c'est pas sur des crédits fléchés
donc porte bien sur la réserve de
précaution
donc ceux là n'ont put pas les budgets
qui ont été adoptées pour ces pour les
établissements en question ce que ce
dont vous parliez merci les quatre
amendements du gouvernement monsieur
mini 109 101 103 107 vous les avez déjà
défendu le la commission favorable je
vais donc mettre aux voix ces
amendements quels sont ceux qui sont
favorables à leur adoption
ceux qui sont contre
ils sont adoptés et le jeu fait voter
sur l'article 5
ceux qui sont favorables à son adoption
il est adopté à l'article 5 bis
l'amendement 38 rectifiée présentée par
monsieur carrère
m
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues jamais
parlé lors de mon intervention en
discussion générale vous l'êtes donc pas
sans ignorer avec quelle violence le
sud-ouest de la france a été frappée par
la tempête klaus du 24 janvier dernier
si le bilan humain est malheureusement
tragique
je vous rappelle que 17 personnes ont
été tuées six en france et 11 en espagne
avec aussi de nombreux blessés le bilan
écologique et économique elle est
également les massifs forestiers ont été
fortement touchées selon les estimations
de l'inventaire forestier national ce
sont plus de 42,5 millions de mètres
cubes de bois qui ont été déracinés dont
la très grande partie 80 14 % dans le
département des landes de la gironde et
du lot-et-garonne
néanmoins n'oublions pas les forêts du
languedoc-roussillon de midi pyrénées
qui ont également subi de lourdes pertes
je rappelle que c'est la deuxième fois
en dix ans et je rappelle hélas que
cette tempête a suivi la tempête de
décembre 99 en janvier ce sont ainsi
plus de 5 à 6 années de récolte qui ont
été à nouveau dévasté les conséquences
économiques sont graves et l'heure est à
la mobilisation de tous les acteurs de
terrain je rappelle pour que vous soyez
sensibiliser encore plus mes chers
collègues que quand on fait tomber un
mètre cube de pain
c'est une tonne de co2 qu'on ne
capturent plus dont imaginez les dégâts
écologiques que représente une telle
tempête en faire un
il est donc indispensable de
reconstituer ce formidable poumon vert
de la france je rappelle simplement
qu'en france la globalité du massif
forestier permet de capturer 10% du co2
émis sur l'ensemble du territoire
d'importants moyens financiers sont donc
nécessaires pour parvenir à remplir ses
objectifs
or les acteurs économiques seuls
sylviculteurs agriculteurs communes
forestières ne peuvent et ne pourront
pas absorber un tel choc et une telle
pression financière
victime de la précédente tempête de 99
et de la baisse récente de la demande
notamment espagnoles pour le logement
ils ne pourront faire face à de tels
investissements
sans une aide significative de l'état et
l'état contribue objectivement néanmoins
face à l'ampleur de cette nouvelle
catastrophe
les autorités ont constaté l'état de
catastrophe naturelle et le gouvernement
a présenté le 13 février dernier un plan
chablis 2009 alors mesdames messieurs ce
plan comprend désormais en 2009 près de
128 millions d'euros alors que
initialement il était prévu 88 millions
d'euros d'autorisations d'engagement
suite à l'adoption l'adoption de
l'amendement de gilles carrez à
l'assemblée nationale sur l'initiative
de nos collègues à qui perd dont le mon
collègue député des landes henri
emmanuelli
si cette avancée nous satisfait en
partie nous espérions montant plus
important des crédits de paiement qui
pourront réellement être investi dès
2009 dans la filière bois
le montant prévu de 89 millions d'euros
de crédits de paiement semble largement
insuffisant pour faire face à la crise
alors j'ai entendu monsieur le ministre
lorsqu'il nous dit mais l'état est
derrière et sera présent et si il y en a
besoin
nous serons là le moment venu
rappelons que ce sont quand même plus de
240 mille emplois qui sont en jeu dans
la filière bois verni le sylviculteur et
34 mille salariés dans la région
aquitaine
il faut mesdames et messieurs que vous
compreniez que cet amendement qui
prévoit une dotation de 300 millions
d'euros pour l'indemnisation des
sylviculteurs est une base de départ
alors moi je ne suis pas plus royalistes
que le roi si je vois que le
gouvernement s'intéresse vraiment
s'intéresse vraiment à ce problème le
prendre à bras le corps et accepte de
nous fournir une réponse qui
nous permet d'envisager que rapidement
il y aura une négociation pour regarder
si on peut trouver par les assurances ou
parler de mobilisation une solution je
me rallierai à une preuve de bonne
volonté mais dans la période je vous
demande de soutenir cet amendement
merci monsieur l'entente en général du
budget la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues et je
voudrais rappeler que pour soutenir la
filière bois qui a été mise à mal par
cette terrible tempête l'enveloppent
global d'un milliard d'euros du plan
chablis 2009 et les mesures adoptées
dans ce cadre apparaissent déjà très
significatif les crédits disponibles en
2009 devrait représenter plus de 138
millions d'euros en autorisations
d'engagement correspondante à de
nouvelles ouvertures à des
redéploiements et à un dégel de la
réserve de précaution sur le programme
fort est la plus grande partie de ces
crédits est destiné aux sylviculteurs
puisque les subventions pour le stockage
et le transport du bois représente à
elle seule 100 millions d'euros enfin
dans la limite d'un montant de 600
millions d'euros de prêts la garantie de
l'état serait en outre apporté au profit
des opérateurs de la filière bois à ce
stade
l'indemnisation direct des sylviculteurs
par l'état à ce stade et à ma
connaissance n'est pas envisagée elle
avait d'ailleurs été écarté après la
tempête de 1999
cependant cependant chers collègues
une réflexion est en cours au niveau
interministériel sur la question des
dispositifs d'assurance dans le secteur
forestier et vous avez vous même fait
allusion à cette problématique convient
de préciser en outre que cet amendement
prévoit une diminution à due concurrence
de l'action 3 du programme conduite et
pilotage des politiques de l'agriculture
il fallait bien que vous trouviez un
gage naturellement ça c'est une
contrainte technique vous proposé de
compenser l'ouverture de 300 millions
d'euros
deux cas liés par une annulation de même
montant concernant les moyens des
directions régionales et départementales
du ministère
nous comprenons bien qu'il s'agit d'un
amendement surtout destiné à questionner
le gouvernement
plusieurs de nos collègues gérard césar
philippe leroy sont intervenus dans la
discussion générale à ce sujet et vous
même avez mis l'accent sur les problèmes
des landes et de la région aquitaine et
monsieur le ministre il est important
que la voix des sylviculteurs puisse
être bien entendu dans cette période
difficile et je je je comprends ce que
dit jean louis carrère gée un témoignage
il y a eu une tempête en 1983 qui a
touché la forêt domaniale de compiègne
comme une onde de choc ce qui se voit
encore très bien aujourd'hui plus de 25
ans après mais bien clair que les demain
à vaincre quand on le touche soi-même du
doigt c'est encore beaucoup plus et
tangibles et je m'associe bien entendu à
l'émotion qui a été exprimé par
l'intermédiaire de notre collègue
carrère merci monsieur marini là
monsieur le
ministre s'il vous plaît madame la
présidente je voudrais dire ont d'abord
au sénateur marini que la commune de
compiègne n'est pas éligible cette fois
ci je vais moins sûr mais je referme
cette parenthèse évidemment le
gouvernement est soucieux d'apporter la
réponse adéquate aux questions qui se
posent dans votre département et dans
les départements avec ont été touchés
par cette terrible tempête le plan je ne
vais pas vous le rappelez vous le
connaissez très bien donc
le rapporteur l'a rappelé également tant
en ce qui concerne les aides spécifiques
en faveur des propriétaires forestiers
en ce qui concerne le reboisement des
parcelles les mesures ciblées pour aider
la mobilisation d'un volume maximum de
bois et pour en assurer la
revalorisation tout ça ce sont des aides
aires de stockage etc
tout ça ce sont des aides qui s'étale
dans le temps et qui ont été discutées
avec la profession ces aides
s'accompagne évidemment de dégrèvements
fiscaux sur l'indemnisation spécifique
de la filière de sylviculture
les sylviculteurs sont largement
bénéficiaires des aides par principe
prévu dans le plan tempête et des aides
aussi pour les communes mais c'est autre
chose qu'il s'agisse donc des aides à la
valorisation des bois ou des aides au
reboisement
les sylviculteurs alors ils peuvent
s'assurer mais aujourd'hui contre les
risques climatiques
ils ont tendance à pas le faire ce
qu'ils considèrent que c'est trop cher
par rapport au bénéfice de leurs
exploitations donc ça ne marche pas donc
en ce qui concerne l'indemnisation et
l'assurance financière ce que j'ai dit
hier je le redis il faut évidemment
réfléchir nous l'avons évoqué vous avez
d'ailleurs évoqué cette réflexion qui
est en cours pour prendre en compte ce
que nous faisons dans le domaine
agricole
mais c'est vrai que ce que nous faisons
dans le domaine agricole ne va pas
aujourd'hui dans le sens d'un fonds
spécifique dédié jeu là vous j'ai déjà
indiqué au sénateur césar bon donc c'est
à un vrai sujet celui de l'indemnisation
on doit y réfléchir la réflexion est
aujourd'hui en cours est engagé le
ministère du budget y participent comme
évidemment le ministère de l'agriculture
sur monsieur carrère oui madame la
présidente pour explication de vote je
voudrais premièrement remercier monsieur
le rapporteur général de de sa réponse
remercier monsieur le ministre de son
début de réponse mais je voudrais
franchement mettre l'accent pour
l'expression s'agissant de l'expression
de de monsieur le rapporteur général
lorsque vous présentez les choses et je
je je conviens qu'il y à un milliard dan
ans 600 millions de prêts bonifiés
c'est pas une d'une dotation vous
l'avais dit après et on n'a pas si vous
voulez les non nommément le grand public
s'imagine que le gouvernement débloque
en milliards non c'est pas vrai le
gouvernement bonifie 600 millions de
prêts est là quand je vous en parle je
vous en parle sans aucune aucune
rancoeur mais je vous dis simplement que
des blocs ans et 600 millions qui
correspondent à une demande de la
profession et donc de ce point de vue il
n'y a pas de problème la demande de la
profession qui est très très très
pressante et de dire mais de grâce ne
nous accordez pas ses 600 millions de
prêts sur cinq ans
nous avons besoin de la longue marche de
trois ans de la durée de ses prêts dans
là dessus monsieur le ministre
j'aimerais que vous puissiez moi je suis
prêt monsieur le ministre a retiré son
amendement
si vous maintenez la formulation que
vous avez indiquée quant à l'attitude du
gouvernement à la négociation en cours
est la seule
le seul argument que je voudrais
développer monsieur le ministre le
dernier il s'agit d'une forêt cultivée
où monsieur le ministre
cette forêt cultivée mériterait qu'on
puisse la prendre en considération comme
on prend en considération les
problématiques agricoles et il me semble
que ce serait peut-être une piste de
sortie mais monsieur le ministre si en
complément de ce que vous nous avez dit
vous accepté cette demande que je
formule de passer de cinq à huit ans
alors je retirerai
non merci pas de monsieur césar
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
j'abonde dans le sens de jaloux carrère
et merci au rapporteur général du budget
mais aussi merci au ministre hier dans
la discussion générale nous avons
invoqué justement c'est pour toutes
cette possibilité d'allonger la durée
des prêts aujourd'hui c'est ce
qu'attendent indivis cutter il est prévu
le 10 avril prochain c'est à dire assène
prochaine manifestation à bordeaux des
sylviculteurs qui viendront donc peut
être bloqué le pont d'aquitaine pendant
une journée avec leurs engins
il est important aujourd'hui qu'on
puisse les rassurer car ceux des dégâts
sont très importants et surtout où la
vente d'hier dans la discussion générale
ils suivent donc une tempête très
importante de 99,2 tempête en disant ça
fait beaucoup
alors nous avons proposé hier donc à
monsieur le ministre de constituer un
groupe de travail pour prévoir pour le
futur justement la possibilité
une assurance qui pourrait être donc
fait en collaboration étroite entre le
ministre de la culture ministre du
budget et tout ceci avec une aide sans
doute de l'europe parce que la forêt
d'aquitaine ne peut plus supporter un
préjudice important
donc merci encore mais nous souhaitons
et comment le ministre s'est engagé hier
à ce que ce soit aujourd'hui qu'une
première partie du déblocage des fonds
pour l'annulation de façon à ce que si
c'est justifié nous puissions dans
quelques quelques mois donc demandé une
nouvelle aide pour justement le
déblaiement de ces chablis qui encore
mon norauto chenaux nos pistes
forestières et qui peuvent poser de gros
problèmes au niveau des incendies car
nous arrivons la saison des incendies
merci monsieur le ministre nous a
demandé la parole oui madame la
présidente sur la demande de
d'allongement en fait des prés de 5 à 8
ans si j'ai bien compris
bon moi je suis j'ai pas d'opposition de
principe si vous le voulez bien je vais
répondre au cours du débat et je suis en
train de regarder ce que ça quels sont
les éléments techniques s'il ya des
points il faut regarder sérieusement et
je vais essayer de vous donner une
réponse d'ici la fin de ce débat c'est
une féministe monsieur carrère bon alors
il me reste une précision je demanderai
aux orateurs qui qu'ils défendent mais
je respecte la position du gouvernement
ou de la commission de veiller à ne pas
utiliser l'argument qui opposerait la
prise en compte de la tempête de 99 et
celle de 2009 je répète une dernière
fois pour qu' il n'y ait pas de
malentendu déplaisant entre nous est
vraiment déplacé vous savez mieux que
moi quelle était la situation économique
de 99 sur le rapporteur général
vous savez ce qu'elle est en 2009 vous
savez comment était l'appel de la
péninsule ibérique et notamment de
l'espagne à tout ce qui est chablis
aquitaine actuellement on passe de 45
euros la tonne à 2 euros je vous assure
que la situation est très différente
excusez moi donc je retire mon amant
devant madame la présidente
merci monsieur carrère donc l'amendement
est retiré et vous défendent également
l'amendement 39 monsieur carrère pour
l'amendement de 39 il est de nature un
petit peu différente
d'autant plus que je suis de ceux qui
considèrent que la réponse qui a été
apportée par le gouvernement
si en matière de sylviculture elle était
amendé et j'espère qu'elle le sera et et
je me rends compte qu'elle commence à
l'être et c'est une grande satisfaction
pour nous que de
nous en rendre compte en matière de
l'agriculture elle avait été proche de
la perfection
je serais tenté de dire elle
correspondait disons ce sera mieux
exprimer ainsi à la demande de la
profession et correspondant à la demande
de la profession
je n'insisterai pas trop longtemps
néanmoins néanmoins les représentants
des chambres départementales et
régionales nous disent que les sommes
prévues sont encore insuffisantes sur la
seule région des landes les pertes sont
estimées à 100 millions d'euros 60
millions pour les productions animales
40 millions pour le secteur des
productions végétales pour les landes le
programme pour faire face aux pertes et
aux dégâts s'élèvent à 57 5 millions
d'euros dont près de la moitié non
assurables les mesures actuelles annoncé
par le ministère de l'agriculture à
savoir 25 millions d'euros sont
nettement insuffisantes pour répondre
aux mesures d'urgence et à l'ensemble
des dégâts dans le secteur agricole
c'est la raison pour laquelle un autre
amendement propose de majorer de 4
millions d'euros les crédits affectés à
l'aide des offices au titre de la
reconstruction pour la filière élevage
et de porter le plafond d'investissement
subventionnable par exploitation de
25000 euros à 50000 euros
pour cela il convient donc de majorer de
4 millions d'euros les crédits du
programme 154 économie et développement
durable de l'agriculture de la pêche et
des territoires destinés à l'action
numéro 15 moyenne de mise en oeuvre des
politiques publiques et gestion des
interventions qui permettrait à l'agencé
de services et de paiement de financer
cette aide supplémentaire
merci quel est l'avis de la commission
résidence sur le ministre mes chers
collègues
il s'agit à nouveau d'un amendement de
questionnement d'un amendement d'appel
lié à la situation économique qui
résulte cette fois ci pour les éleveurs
de la même
tempête donc monsieur le ministre sans
doute avez vous des éléments
d'information que nous écouteront avec
attention
merci monsieur marriner monsieur le
ministre
oui madame la présidente donc à l'aide à
l'investissement dans les abris
d'élevage a été calibré à six parce que
c'est au fond l'analyse des services sis
parce que ça relève de l'analyse de ces
risques
donc je pense que ça correspond au
besoin encore une fois si ça ne
correspond pas aux besoins durant
l'année
le gouvernement répondra les lignes je
lui ai déjà indiqué et je le leur ai
indique volontiers c'est vrai également
pour les aides aux investissements
complété par plusieurs mesures du plan
tempête en faveur des éleveurs avicoles
pour indemniser notamment les les
éleveurs donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
ressource a été prévu en fonction des
analyses faites sur le terrain si j'aime
mais il faut un peu plus je viens nous
nous reverrons je ne ferme en aucun cas
la porte à dire le gouvernement ne ferme
pas la porte à cela
monsieur carrère après avoir entendu la
réponse de monsieur le rapporteur
général et surtout celle de monsieur le
ministre je remercie et je retire mon
amendement
merci monsieur le sénateur je mets donc
aux voix l'article 5bis ceux qui sont
favorables à son adoption voudront bien
le manifester en levant la main ceux qui
sont contre il est adopté
nous passons à l'article additionnel
après l'article 5 bis avec l'amendement
numéro 37
monsieur carrère oui madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mesdames
messieurs mes chers collègues je ne
voudrais pas vous lasser mais vous allez
tous comprendre qu'en sénateurs et que
le sénateur que je suis avec certaines
de mes collègues nous pensions aussi aux
collectivités territoriales
les pertes économiques et financières ne
se feront pas sentir uniquement pour les
sylviculteurs et les agriculteurs les
communes forestières sont elles aussi
les victimes de catastrophes naturelles
or elles aussi sont totalement absentes
du plan chablis 2009 présenté par le
gouvernement aucune mesure
d'indemnisation et de soutien n'est
prévu à leur profit alors que nombreux
de leurs équipements ont été détruits
par les intempéries et que la forêt
constitué pour elle une source
importante de revenus
je je je préfère vous le dire très
concrètement comme je le ressens chers
amis je remercie d'ailleurs le sénat de
l'effort qu'il fait lui-même et par la
bouche de son président en l'expression
qu'il a eue
lorsqu'il était venu en gironde de
s'adressant aux collectivités
territoriales mais je demande au
gouvernement dont la réponse de madame
la ministre de l'intérieur a été quelque
peu difficile difficile à comprendre
lorsqu'elle était venue me voir de
vraiment préciser les aides qui
pourraient intervenir auprès des
communes forestières qui ont été
sérieusement mise à mal
du point de vue budgétaire quelles
seront ses les aides de ce gouvernement
si les aides qui sont prévues par le
gouvernement sont de nature à rassurer
le sénateur que je suis je retirerais
bien évidemment ce projet d'amendement
qui est aussi un amendement d'appel et
de discussions mais si tel n'était pas
le cas bien évidemment je me verrais
dans l'obligation de le maintenir
merci monsieur marini pour la commission
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues là il faut
entrer un peu dans la technique rappelé
que le fonds catastrophes naturelles cat
nat et est en principe destiné à faire
face à des deux mains
je dirais de taille intermédiaire et non
pas à des catastrophes d'ampleur
nationale pour lesquelles il est fait
appel à la solidarité nationale
ce fonds a été créé par la loi de
finances pour 2008 initialement doté de
20 millions d'euros puis abondé de 10
millions d'euros supplémentaires en 2009
à ce jour seuls 3 8 millions d'euros ont
été consommés sur les 30 millions
disponibles par ailleurs est l'objet de
votre amendement chers collègues étant
d'indemniser les communes frappées par
la tempête klaus et le fond catnat je le
rappelle destinés à des dégâts que je
disais de taille intermédiaire
c'est-à-dire d'une valeur inférieure à 4
millions d'euros ne sera pas utilisée à
cette fin et l'état fera jouer la
solidarité nationale en dotant
directement les crédits adéquate sur le
programme concours spécifique et
administration de la mission relations
avec les collectivités territoriales
donc je pense que votre amendement est à
nouveau un amendement d'appel qu'en tant
que tel il n'atteindrait pas son objet
compte tenu du solde disponible et des
finalités du fonds catastrophe naturelle
mais je pense que monsieur le ministre
compte tenu de l'intérêt d'un certain
nombre de collègues et de vous-même pour
ce sujet va nous apporter les éléments
d'information nécessaires
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
la présente je remercie rapporteur
général pour effectivement ces
explications qu'il fallait
donnez le une mission d'inspection
aujourd'hui qui est en train d'achever
le recensement des dégâts sur le terrain
et donc qui devrait rendre ses
conclusions d'ici le dit si bien avant
l'été sur le fond de catastrophe
naturelle en réalité il intervient donc
sur des sur des dégâts aux biens qui ne
sont pas assurables et lorsque ces
débats ces dégâts pardon pardon ne
dépasse pas 4 millions d'euros donc si
le montant est supérieur à 4 millions va
on se retrouve dans le domaine de la
solidarité nationale et l'état ouvrira
les crédits nécessaires en fonction de
la mission d'inspection et sur la
mission elle-même relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
dans un décret d'avancé ou dans un
collectif budgétaire à venir
donc on n'a pas besoin d'ouvrir en
réalité de crédit sur le fond la
catastrophe naturelle parce que si c'est
inférieur à 4 il a les crédits
nécessaires et 6 et supérieures à 4 à ce
moment là c'est un autre sujet et nous
ouvrirons décret d'avancé
monsieur carrère là je suis un peu moins
satisfaits jeu parce qu'il me semble que
je n'ai pas bien compris le enveloppe de
4 millions sur le canada c'est une
enveloppe globale ou une enveloppe
globale
oui donc là à coup sûr au nez au delà de
4 millions d'euros donc il est évident
que il s'agit bien comme vous le disiez
monsieur le rapporteur général de faire
jouer la solidarité nationale la seule
alors je demande une dernière précision
si tel était le cas et si vous en prenez
l'engagement dans le cadre de
l'inspection générale qui va rendre ses
conclusions qu'elle serait
approximativement les délais de réponse
que l'on pourrait proposer aux
collectivités locales concernées par la
tempête klaus
est-ce que c'est mi année 2009 fin de
l'année 2009
vous le comprenez ça a une incidence
très significative sur les projets de
budget si j'obtiens cette réponse
excusez moi d'être dans une situation de
négociation
madame la présidente à ce moment là je
retirerais mon amendement sur le mini
serait ce que vous pouvez répondre aux
interrogations de monsieur carrère
dépanner m'en lasser le ministère de
l'intérieur qui gère cela visiblement il
n'est pas là donc le la question et que
moi je sais que les missions
d'inspection se termine vers le mois de
juin donc on aura l'inventaire donc
j'imagine qu'à partir de ce moment là
les choses pour ans les assez vite fin
ce serait
ridicule de les faire durer donc je vois
là je ne peux que vous donner la date de
fin de l'émission après comment ça se
passe je pense qu'il faut que le
ministère de l'intérieur puisse vous le
dire on va essayer de trouver la réponse
mais c'est en cours d'année en tout cas
monsieur carrez à la douce satisfait par
la réponse côté je suis moyennement
satisfaits excusez moi madame la
présidente
moi je pense que qu'on pourrait
envisager peut-être un décret d'avancé
mais compte tenu du soutien de la
commission et de l'expression de la
commission je retire mon amendement
je vous en remercie le l'article 5 ter
ne présentent pas d'amendement je le
mets aux voix ceux qui sont favorables à
son adoption voudront bien levé la main
ceux qui sont contre il est adopté
de même pour l'article 6 même vote et
nous passons à l'article 7 avec un
amendement numéro 47 défendu par madame
boulet à madame rick excusez moi je ne
faisais pas je n'ai pas vu sur l'article
r la parole sur l'arctique rapidement
parce que
un des amendements du gouvernement
traite à l'état des deux
des de la dotation finalement
budgétaires qui sont alloués aux
nouveaux commissaires à la
réindustrialisation et ça me donne
l'occasion d'attirer l'attention et sai
clara aussi le débat que nous allons
avoir tout à l'heure à l'article 11
notamment à propos de l'amendement de
notre collègue jean arthuis sur le
délicat problème des rémunérations et
comme il s'agit de ré industrialisation
comme il s'agit aussi de soutenir
notamment la filière automobile
je voudrais quand même dire que chaque
jour apporte son lot de nouvelles pas
très bonne quand même puisqu'il s'agit
de soutenir la filière auto m et
automobiles et ça a été évoqué le
problème de la gouvernance d'entreprise
lors de la question que notre groupe
mais mis à l'ordre du jour la question
orale du 26 mars dernier sur
l'automobile et bien on apprend que
le fonds de modernisation des
équipementiers automobiles je vous
rappelle le chiffrage c'est 690 millions
d'euros auquel en plus les sous
traitants du mal à avoir accès mais tel
n'est pas le problème et on apprend
aujourd'hui que psa auraient à
provisionner à fin décembre 2008
des retraites surcomplémentaires pour
ses dirigeants pour un montant de 690
millions d'euros
donc ça pose quand même bien le problème
et d'autres entreprises cotées 1
chaque pause quand même le problème de
la destination des fonds bon exceller
légalité des sommes qui fait que je vous
donne cette information
j'espère qu'elle sera démentie mais bon
les commissaires à la
réindustrialisation c'est bien mais si
c'est comme ça que ça se passe et un
problème merci à l'amérique
je demande à madame goulet de présenter
son amendement numéro 47
madame le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues à l'article l
article 7 mille et une inscription de
crédit pour 60 millions
et demi visant au rachat de la salle
pleyel donc c'est une salle de concert
qui avait été acquise par un particulier
dans le cadre du démembrement des actifs
du crédit lyonnais en 98 et voilà que
dans le collectif alors que nous sommes
dans une situation un peu difficile que
madame briques annoncent attend nombreux
enfin rappelle que chaque jour apporte
son lot de mauvaises nouvelles
l'état nous demande de 60 millions et
demi pour acheter la salle pleyel
alors cette dépense me paraissait
inopportune quant au fait d'être placé
dans une loi de finances rectificative
elle concerne le budget de la culture le
rapporteur général du budget a rappelé
que cette dépense avait été inscrite
sans que les domaines eu l'occasion et
eu l'occasion de faire un rapport sur le
sujet par ailleurs il n'y a pas non plus
d'expertisé du besoin d'une salle de
concerts supplémentaires dans paris donc
de deux choses l'une où cette dépense
est nécessaire et il faudrait qu'on nous
le prouve
où paris a besoin d'une salle de concert
il faut qu'on nous le prouve ô le
ministère de la culture a trop d'argent
et dans ces cas là je suis sûr que tous
nos territoires sont bien content de
récupérer 60 millions de budget quoi
qu'il en soit cet amendement vise avoir
supprimé cette ligne budgétaire qui me
semble parfaitement inopportune en
période de crise économique
la commission a marre
merci quel est l'avis de la commission
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues bon voilà
un débat intéressant dans mon rapport
écrit je me suis efforcé de détailler
les données de cette affaire et et il en
résulte que la proposition qui nous est
faite est une optimisation patrimonial
l'état est engagé vis-à-vis du
propriétaire privé de la salle pleyel
soit à continuer à payer un loyer
substantielle tous les ans soit à faire
usage d'une option de rachat de
l'ensemble immobilier compte tenu du
prix
du prix de revient initial du bien et
des travaux d'aménagement très important
qui ont été réalisés le tout devant
s'établir de mémoire à une somme de
l'ordre de 63 millions d'euros la valeur
de rachat pour 60 millions d'euros par
rapport à cet élément de comparaison ne
paraît pas aberrante
bien entendu on peut aussi regarder les
éléments de référence sur le marché se
demande est ce que vaut une salle de
concert qui ne peut être qu'une salle de
concert et plus particulièrement dans le
contexte de l'immobilier parisien le 1er
avril 2009
et là on peut être amené à des
réflexions différents toutefois pacta
sunt servanda les contrats sont ce
qu'ils sont
n'est ce pas et il convient de les
respecter
maintenant là où les choses se
compliquent c'est que l'on nous explique
que l'état achète pour rétrocéder non
plus à une partie privée mais à la cité
de la musique est un établissement
public du dit et à comment va faire la
cité de la musique pour racheter et
payer à l'état
les 60 millions d'euros qui n'auront été
finalement qu'une avance de trésorerie
mais c'est tout simple mes chers
collègues en s'endettant
et alors c'est là que je me trouve un
peu en porte à faux parce qu'en tant que
porte parole de la commission quelque
sorte est bon souvent arc bouté sur
l'orthodoxie budgétaire comme vous
l'êtes aussi monsieur le ministre dans
votre rôle
le fait pour un établissement public de
l'état d'emprunter à des conditions
forcément plus onéreuse que celle
affectée aux emprunts de l'état
pour rembourser le dit état qui aurait
fait une avance bon à la limite si on
applique ce principe à la salle pleyel
il faut admettre que toutes les
universités tous les établissements
publics quels qu'ils soient vont pouvoir
s'endetter pour réaliser leurs
investissements
et comme le disait le sapeur camember si
je ne me trompe quand les bornes sont
franchies a plus de limite ou le
contraire bon donc j'ai un peu de peine
monsieur le ministre à me retrouver en
termes de gouvernance budgétaire dans
cette opération
bon maintenant est est ce que cette
opération permet de faire l'économie
d'une salle de concert supplémentaire
dans la capitale peut-être que ça serait
la vraie réponse apportée à madame
boulet qui est soucieuse à juste titre
du bon emploi des deniers publics en
période de crise de l'exemplarité de
l'état et en même temps d'une
répartition équitable des efforts
notamment d'équipements culturels entre
paris et le reste de la france
qu'il s'agisse des régions forestières
ou des autres régions voilà donc
l'amendement de madame boulet paraît
être intéressant en tout cas il peut
permettre d'initier un débat et qui nous
permettent de trancher en toute
connaissance de cause si monsieur
legendre me présidente mes chers
collègues la commission affaires
culturelles ne s'est pas saisie cet
article considérant qu'il s'agissait
d'une opération purement financière
n'ayant aucun impact sur la politique
culturelle en faveur de la musique la
salle pleyel comme on l'a rappelé et est
possédé par un propriétaire privé qui
s'était engagé en 2004 à financer sa
restauration complète
en contrepartie la cité de la musique
avait signé un contrat de bail
pendant 50 ans avec une clause d'option
d'achat qu'elle pouvait exercer à tout
moment le propriétaire a effectué 27
millions d'euros de travaux dans la
salle et 3 billions sur les bureaux
attenants la cité de la musique a estimé
qu'il est
aujourd'hui intéressant d'acheter cet
immeuble plutôt que de le louer compte
tenu des cours actuels du marché
la dépense prévue est de 65 millions
d'euros au lieu de 130
à la fin du bail l'objet de l'article 7
et donc de lui consentir une avance pour
financer cet achat avec le montant du
loyer la cité de la musique souscrire à
un emprunt
c'est vrai mais l'opération a un effet
nul sur les finances publiques la
commission affaires culturelles ne s'y
est pas opposé car il n'y a aucune
ponction sur des crédits destinés à
d'autres opérations soit à paris soit en
région
quant à la programmation actuelle de la
salle pleyel elle n'est pas remise en
cause
ce qui devrait retenir notre attention
c'est effectivement le projet qui existe
par ailleurs à la cité de la musique de
construire un nouvel auditorium
symphonique de 2400 places dont la
livraison serait prévue en 2012
on peut s'interroger sur l'opportunité
de disposer de plusieurs salles de
concert dans la capitale
s'interrogeait peut-être sur sur
investissement à paris par rapport à ce
qui existe ailleurs
et ce qui nous semblerait souhaitable
c'est que là qu'on accepte
l'opération menée par la cité de la
musique lui permettant de s'approprier
cette salle de concert existantes et à
terre nous reviendra moins cher mais de
rappeler qu'aucune décision ne peut être
prise
on doit construire comme prise quant à
la construction par ailleurs d'un
auditorium à la cité de la musique et si
l'amendement est le débat qui a cours
ici pouvait permettre de clarifier ainsi
la situation
je crois que ce débat aurait été utile
merci monsieur le ministre un moulin à
répondre alors
madame la présidente monsieur tu pas
misé la culture donc je vais répondre en
tant que ministre du budget ce sera donc
plus peut-être liée essentiellement à
caractère économique de cette démarche
la salle pleyel
elle a été achetée à l'époque où cdr
comme vous le dites par un propriétaire
privé qui a fait des travaux etc
beaucoup de travaux et dans un contexte
familial qui était le sien à l'époque
aujourd'hui le contrat qui a été signé
avec la cité de la musique pour la
location de cette salle fait apparaître
une montée en puissance du loyer très
importante puis après deal dans 2054 une
propriété qui revient à l'état
après avoir versé beaucoup de loyer
c'est à dire à peu près quand on cumule
l'ensemble des loyers en valeur sa
d'hommes 134 millions d'euros donc ce
sont des sommes très importantes
aujourd'hui le propriétaire souhaite
s'en défaire pour des raisons aussi
familiale dans laquelle on n'a pas
rentré
mais au fond c'est une opportunité qui
est qu'ils peuvent faire pour qu'on lève
cette cette option et nous pouvons la
levée ce qui nous empêchera à ce
moment-là de payer un loyer qui est un
loyer quand même très élevé de 57
millions d'euros par an qui est indexée
à 2,2 pour cent par an alors évidemment
la cité de la musique va devoir
emprunter et ce qui n'est jamais
monsieur le rapporteur général une bonne
idée que de laisser un opérateur
emprunter mais au moins aussi des
opérations qui sont faites au cas par
cas avec des autorisations au cas par
cas donc nous pouvons l'autorisé et nous
pourrons aussi surtout bénéficié des
bureaux parce qu'en rachetant pour 60 et
quelques millions d'euros 70,5 millions
d'euros nous rachetons la salle mais
nous rachetons aussi des bureaux et la
valeur locative de ses bureaux fin la
valeur de marché de loyers de ses
bureaux sis
mais l'information est bonne est de
l'ordre de 1,7 million d'euros donc il
semblerait que l'opération soit
économiquement rentable si les chiffres
qui me sont donnés sont bons donc il est
intéressant de lever cette option
d'achat maintenant c'est une opération
plutôt gagnante pour pour l'état et
c'est surtout une opération qui permet
là d'éviter de rentrer dans une
situation familiale visiblement
compliquée du propriétaire et sécurisé
la propriété à ce moment-là de l'état
c'est clair l'état est propriétaire
n'est plus lié par un loyer par une
clause compliqué d'indexation de ceux de
ce loyer par une option d'achat qui
augmente chaque année c'est à dire que
si on veut acheter on va plus achetés à
60 et demi mais l'année prochaine à 60
de l'année après 63 donc on achète à ce
prix là on emprunte il est vrai mais en
même temps des propriétaires d'une salle
on loue les bureaux on garde la salle et
puis après il ya une politique de salle
de spectacle une salle de concert qui
relèvent pas du ministère du budget mais
qui relève du ministère de la culture
donc c'est une opération qui est une
opération bonne pour l'état qui permet
de se sortir d'une situation je ne
trouve pas très clair vis-à-vis du
propriétaire
merci monsieur gaillard va demander la
parole un présidente
je tenais intervenir en tant
qu'apporteurs spéciales dont la culture
la commission des finances
je trouve que les explications que nous
en donner et le monsieur le rapporteur
général et monsieur le ministre
extrêmement claire du point de vue
financier il est certain que cette
opération n'est pas une mauvaise
opération du point de vue financier
elle deviendrait mauvaise peut-être dans
l'avenir c'est ce qu'a dit monsieur le
président le la de la commission des
affaires culturelles si en plus dans les
années qui viennent on faisait ont donné
suite à ce grand projet qui est
actuellement dans la cité de la musique
et qui vont ne m'insulte ont pas
l'avenir on ne sait pas ce qui se
passera dans dix ans c'est peut-être que
d'ici là la crise sera terminée que
l'état serait de serait devenu riche
actuellement l'opération pleyel est
bonne mais il est clair parce que c'est
l'endroit d'abord la famille elle est un
lieu prestigieux et c'est l'endroit où
viennent facilement les auditeurs et les
amateurs de musique
ce sera plus difficile de les envoyer à
la cité à la ville est bon donc moi je
pense que c'est une extrêmement c'est
une opération qui s'interdit est très
intéressante
c'est une occasion qui ne se retrouvera
peut-être pas vous me direz la salle
pleyel existera toujours mais elle est
louée dans des conditions assez
difficiles je moi personnellement je
trouve que la france est déjà très en
retard en ce qui concerne les salles de
concert on n'a rien de comparable à ce
qui existe par exemple à rome on est
vraiment tout à fait en arrière de la
main on en matière musicale en matière
de salles de concerts à paris et en
province aussi d'ailleurs mais la sphère
de la salle pleyel n'ôte rien aux
grandes villes de province elle existe
cette femme voilà et on sort ensemble
sur la maîtrise définitive donc moi
personnellement je ne voterai pas
l'amendement des madame goulet en dépit
de son extraordinaire vitae
merci monsieur gayant monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
aujourd'hui la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
cette opération a a quand même un
caractère un peu singulier au regard des
bonnes pratiques de gestion immobilière
de l'état monsieur le ministre comment
se fait-il que l'état ait pu s'engager
sur 50 ans avec un loyer aussi élevé 1
million 500 mille et vous nous dites que
ce loyer va être indexés et donc
atteindre des niveaux très élevés au
fond ce qui fait la valeur de la salle
c'est moins la situation du marché si
tenté qu'il y ait un marché que cette
convention signée par l'état comment
sait-il que france domaine n'ait pas été
saisie vous êtes le ministre des comptes
publics et du budget on est là en face
de deux failles dans les procédures de
l'état de la gestion immobilière de
l'étang lorsque l'état s'engage pour 50
ans et c'est à dire que le parlement
doit viser de telles opérations est ce
que cela fait partie des engagements
hors bilan quelque sorte car s'engager
pour 50 ans un raison d'un loyer de 1
million 500 mille par an c'est
significatif
donc est-ce que cela vous aiderai
monsieur le ministre si le parlement
s'opposait au dénouement de cette
opération pour pouvoir la renégocier
peut-être obtenir un prix plus conforme
à l'intérêt de l'état
merci monsieur de raincourt monsieur de
raincourt alors la présidente sue
ministre mes chers collègues je dois
dire que j'ai découvert sur le tard
l'amendement déposé par madame boulet
mais je ne lui fais naturellement aucun
reproche c'est la disposition qui est
visé par l'amendement que j'ai
découverte sur le tard et ça c'est vrai
que c'est un peu regrettable j'avais
pris la peine de lire le document du
gouvernement et ça ne figurait pas
dedans bien
hier matin je n'avais pas pu pour des
raisons de calendrier donc on vous
recommande calendrier assister à la
commission des finances puisque se
tenait simultanément la réunion du
groupe que j'ai l'honneur de présider et
au cours de laquelle nous étions assez
spontanément enclins à suivre la
recommandation qui figure dans
l'amendement de madame boulet depuis
j'ai quand même essayé de me renseigner
je suis donc allé à la pêche aux
renseignements
et c'est pas si facile que ça
mais néanmoins on voit bien à cet
instant que le débat a beaucoup
progressé
effectivement il s'agit je crois d'une
occasion ou d'une opportunité ce serait
peut-être plus approprié qu'il
interrompt la séance pour prendre la
direction de londres pour la conférence
de presse commune de nicolas sarkozy et
d'angela merkel
à quelques heures de l'ouverture du
sommet du g20 qui réunit je vous le
rappelle
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement des
vingt principales économies mondiales
tout de suite donc la conférence de
presse de nicolas sarkozy
une conférence un sommet très important
pour l'avenir du monde
les enjeux sont de taille le sommet de
washington qui s'était déroulé sous
présidence française
avait été demandé par l'union européenne
seule vie était un sommet au cours
duquel on avait fait part de nos
intentions
ici nous sommes un sommet où des
décisions devront être prises et
transformées en actions
l'allemagne et la france veillerons à ce
qu'il ne s'agisse pas de pure
déclaration mais que ses décisions
soient transformées en actes c'est
pourquoi nous suivons